Frank Isola New York Daily News NBA
columnist insider all basketball
everything I love this dude they call
him the Iceman I called Frankie Frank
how are you my friend Michael Rapaport
the man who stole seen in small-time
crooks yeah you out acted Woody Allen
and then in the big three l thought that
Brian Scalabrine would be the big deal
turns out it to you and Ice Cube Brian
Scalabrine nobody in a big three yeah
you tell you something when I'm done
with Brian Scalabrine they're gonna be
calling me to white mumble hey I'm
taking the name I'm taking the game
Frankie ice let's just jump into this
okay I'm trying not to get my blood
pressure up give myself a some sort of
ailment the New York Knicks somehow
someway be guts the heart the soul the
breath to life Charles Oakley is banned
for a year from Madison Square Garden
because of the now famous Charles Oakley
incident they banned Charles Oakley huh
no I ban you I'm not going back to the
garden me I'm not going back to the
garden until the ban is lifted what do
you know about this band how do you feel
about this ban on the great Charles
Oakley the great New York Nick Charles
Oakley
yeah and I kind of agree with you on
this whole thing it's really a sad
moment to have a player like that you
know someone who the fans always
identified with because you know New
York because I think this is true of
every town people like to think of
themselves as blue-collar workers and
here chain Charles Oakley a guy that's
diving into the crowd for loose balls
and spent so much time diving for loose
balls on the court to see him on the
ground at Madison Square Garden for all
the wrong reasons
you know getting into it with all these
security guards and being dragged out
and arrested it was it was really sad
now Michael Jordan with the help of NBA
Commissioner Adam Silver though they
tried to broker some kind of peace and
Jim Dolan was involved in the meeting as
well I was hoping that they could kind
of come to a settlement there but I know
that Charles was really humiliated by
the whole thing happening some of the
things that can go
it said publicly when he referred to
Charles is being drunk and maybe having
a drinking problem I really think that
that bothers Charles as well it's it's
unfortunate it really is that a guy like
that should be identified with the
organization I think there was you know
a role for him in the organization that
doesn't mean it's an expo in anything
but I think over the years you're going
to get a half around some of these big
men that the Knicks have and it's it's
really bad is that to me it's the optics
are really poor as well that a guy like
Charles Oakley isn't gonna be a smelly
not associated with the Knicks advance
on the building for a year which to be
honest oh my god you probably notice
talking to I know he was into thrilled
about going back there anyway so it's
not like I'm not so sure he's looking at
it as a punishment yeah I agree
Frank isolus is Michael Rapaport on the
line Carmelo Anthony what's the deal how
is this going to play out this is
ridiculous just give me the whole mix
ting Carmelo Christophe porzingis and
the Knicks 2017 2018 season what's going
to happen
well Canelo is still kind of convinced
that the Knicks are going to trade him
to use them and that was kind of the
agreement that they had come to because
Carlo had gone to them before the draft
bill Jackson was still with the team at
this time and he asked them will you
give me a buyout and I think though
Jackson was kind of all for that and I'm
sure that this probably led to Phil
being ousted because Jim Dolan was
thinking hang on a second
I have to give Carmelo Anthony close to
fifty four million dollars to go away I
can give you twenty four million dollars
to go well I solve a couple of problems
and I probably saved myself thirty
million dollars in the process so they
weren't going to go for the buyout now
they set the Carmelo will you waive your
trade no trade clause if you find the
right field they said that's what we
want to do and then then they told
Carmelo and his people go out and get us
a deal bring the deal to us and we'll
decide whether or not we want to do it
and I think they were pretty close with
Houston now Ryan Anderson would be
involved in the deal and I know you have
a great agent Michael but Ryan Anderson
might have a better agent yeah four
years eighty million from Houston and he
still has three years 60 million coming
to him so the Nixon rightfully so don't
seem to want to do that feel so that's
what it kind of stuck right now I think
ideally I think the Knicks field is fine
I'm sure McMahon still this way they
would
but Carmelo's away there's no trade
clause and a breeder would deal with the
Cleveland Cavaliers if there was so many
can get Kyrie Irving involved but I
think Carmelo looks at it this way
LeBron he probably feels is going to opt
out at right next season and Carmelo
doesn't want to hop that after his deal
next year because he's making 28 million
dollars two years from now and he
probably doesn't think he can make that
money up so his skills why should I go
to Cleveland if a bronze not going to be
there in two years right up with you
know Iman Shumpert jr. slip it's like
I'm back on the Knicks except I'm in
Cleveland yeah I mean I think it's I
don't know man how this is going to work
out I know that you know Phil's gone but
the damage that Phil did listen somehow
or another he made Carmelo into a
sympathetic figure the tweeting I think
the whole thing was ridiculous Kyrie
Irving you brought up possibly coming to
the Knicks is that is that even
something that Knicks fans and that
basketball fans should even think about
is it even possible I I definitely think
it's possible but it's made a lot more
complicated by the fact that the Knicks
aren't going to give up Chris pepper
Zynga store should they the idea is to
add to Chris Adler think it's not how to
make a move where you're giving up your
great player picking you know your guy
who you think could be an all-star
caliber player to bring back career but
the thing is to try to add to kristaps
porzingis I'm sure the Knicks are trying
to figure out you know a million
different ways that they could bring in
Kyrie Irving
now if I'm the Cleveland Cavaliers
though Kyrie Irving is under contract
for two more years and if you wait until
December 15th that's what a majority of
free agents are eligible to be traded
guys that were signed this summer so
that creates or options for you I know
David Griffin said on ESPN yesterday
they former general manager that he
believes that caroms will definitely be
traded the key now will be if you're
going to get traded before training camp
begins because as you know I'm rooting
for Kaos so there'd be nothing better
than seeing Kyrie Irving have to show up
training camp with LeBron James and that
whole drama would have to happen so I
don't know what Cleveland's timeline is
I do know this you have to try to get
the best deal for yourself regardless
where you going to trade him and you
know David references something
interesting yesterday the story had come
out that it will forward that it was 14
are you ever engaged on the list - of
course they'll have to abide by that
list never no trade clause but it was
Miami San Antonio the Knicks in
Minnesota but yesterday David Griffin
twice referenced the Boston Celtics as
teams that Kerry wants to play for so
apparently the Boston Celtics are on
that list as well and you know we didn't
hear about so now it's a matter of if
you're Cleveland do you want to trade
them in your conference to the team and
for all intents and purposes is the
second best team in the East I still
look at it like if I can get that for
example Isiah Thomas J crowd or a future
first-round pick I think I'd have to
think long and hard about them what are
your thoughts on Andrew Wiggins uh Frank
he's looking for a max money the owner
of the Minnesota Timberwolves is looking
for a sit-down which I don't know how
that becomes a public thing you we you
know like we're going to have a little
like a coffee maybe high tea and figure
out if we're going to pay them when I
think it's totally understandable you
want 150 million dollars we should be
able to have like maybe we get like some
french fries and some tater tots and we
discuss it in Minnesota I think Andrew
Wiggins is going to be I think he's a
very good player I think he's going to
continue to get better I'm not going to
say he's Kobe I'm not going to say he's
gonna have that kind of career the way
he plays the mid-range the turnaround
the explosiveness he reminds me just the
way he played I don't know about the
mentality I certainly don't think he
dresses as well as Kobe did he's a
little far out but what do you think of
what do you think of Andrew Wiggins and
what's going on in Minnesota because
they have a team there yes they
absolutely do and I think they have the
right coach as well I like the moves
they make during the offseason I got
Jimmy Butler you know a top 10 top 15
player in the league Taj Gibson is a
terrific world player who would have
been with Tom Thibodeau in Chicago and
then you're ready to maul Crawford who
on any given night to give you 25 points
off the bench and if you go if you're
looking Minnesota last year they had
leads in a lot of games I think they
blew more double-digit leads at any team
in the league and I think a lot of that
had to do maybe a little bit with depth
but I think a lot to do with experience
and now that you're adding guys like Taj
Gibson
Jimmy Butler now you're gonna have
Carlin Anthony pounds and Wiggins a year
old another thing with Wiggins you
mentioned the mentality I think that's
one thing and I think
a lot of NBA people talk about his motor
and he just you know there's he happily
that tries to want to be great and I
think that's what the owner was
referring to him he want to sit down and
talk to it's funny I looked it up it was
the biggest contract that they ever
handed out was six years hundred twenty
six million dollars the Kevin Garnett by
the way that contract that they gave
Garnett was all the way back in the 97
98 season so Garnett stand was making
crazy money 20 years ago oh I think it's
right to want to sit down I don't know
why like you feel the need to say that
publicly because I found the player and
his family and his agent I'm thinking
like why does he only want to sit down
why did he have to make like this big
scene about the two of us talking
obviously anytime you're going to pay
some 150 million dollars I think you'd
want to talk to them first and make sure
that everyone's on the same page I
thought the fact that the owner came out
publicly because that's certainly not
Tom Thibodeau zwey remember Scott Laden
is the GM and you know from you know
being around the Knicks in New York
Scott Lane if it's for two words in New
York so you know that's that is style as
well but I think they're on the right
debt I did hear this stuff how about a
deal where you did wig enough once week
and signs you can't trade him for a
while but what about Wiggins to OKC Paul
George to Cleveland
Kerry Irving to the Minnesota symbols
listen I don't know why anybody would
want to go to Cleveland at this point
Frank because it's going to be a one and
done season LeBron James is leaving
they're not winning the championship
next year so it's going to really want
to get out of there so as far as I'm
concerned I don't see why anybody like
of all the guys you mentioned Paul
George Andrew Wiggins
known of these guys you know Kyrie
Irving I get it party's over but let me
ask you this though did you LeBron okay
well we think the Warriors for at least
next this season coming up in the
following season gonna be good to go
then I think klay Thompson
becomes a free agent by then who knows
like how the whole thing will play out
with Golden State but if I'm LeBron I
know I have a pretty good sense I'm
going to go to the finals this year and
if I stay in the East one more year I
can get to the finals again and then
I'll probably go west if it's going to
be the Lakers whatever because I don't
know if he goes to the Lakers succeeding
is he beating gold and say nope I don't
so why not stay nice and give yourself a
chance to get to a file that you know
your four wins away from winning a
championship as opposed to going to the
conference that the war is right I think
he's eventually leaving I just wonder if
it's after this upcoming season
or maybe he signs up for one more season
knowing that he could still rule East
and then that would be what that would
be nine straight file that because the
next two years which is pretty impressed
I mean it's very impressive as much as I
like to uh antagonize the quote-on-quote
King he's incredibly impressive
I enjoyed that left my taconite it's too
funny all the videos and stuff Oh a
video rate he's radio cold really it
he's radio gold he's TV Goldie's
Instagram gold
it's a roadie with the boldest aha um
all right Frank Isola I appreciate you
taking a time um look forward to the NBA
season but I got to be honest Frank I'm
done I'm finished role of shenanigans
the Opera it's not Falcon Crest it's the
NBA offseason
I've got enough I'm looking forward to
baby it's amazing how long it's gone on
is it what do you want me to say to your
boy Scalabrine when I taught them
tomorrow more you tell them say you know
you're gonna be known as Scalabrine
Michael Rapaport is coming for the name
white minor that hurt Rick Barry wants
to cut him ha ha it's a lot of fun the
big three and Scalabrine is my guy I
love that dude I know you guys do a good
job together on this podcast and
everything those interviews you guys
stupid for the games are pretty good
well Frank thank you for taking the time
I'll talk to you soon
I'm serious about my band with the New
York Knicks I'm done you been over three
year I'm finished I'm not going for you
not that not that not that it took a lot
of like smell like I'm a real freedom
fighter because not going to see the New
York Knicks in 2017 2018 is an easy
thing so so it's not like I'm going to
be like white knuckling it to get to the
garden to see you know Ron Baker start
another game for the Knicks in LA you'll
save a little bit of money here when
they finally get good Frank thanks for
taking the time I appreciate it hi
Michael I'll talk to you
alright so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on
Oh stations across the country and
audience if you like my videos we shoot
down tomorrow I'll shoot a short time
ago to figure out your al-qaeda catch